okay this is the reelection result for
the Birkenhead constituency I am
mcLaughlin being the returning officer
at the election for a member of
parliament for the birkenhead
constituency do hereby give notice that
the number of votes recorded for each
candidate is as follows
brain Alan John Liberal Democrats 1118
cloth Jane Louise and Stephanie green
party 943 field Frank Labour Party
33,000 god
[Applause]
gardener Stewart and Anthony the
Conservative Party candidate 8044 the
number the number of fallow papers
rejected was 108 and I do hear pea by
declare that Frank field is duly elected
as the Member of Parliament many places
this evening one is to have our mayor
declare the result I'm immensely
grateful to her for being here tonight
there's a huge list of thanks to George
- Andrew Joanna who spearheaded this
campaign but all the workers both from
obviously Birkenhead they spread around
other seats as well and from London for
this terrific result I'm immensely
grateful to them all of us are grateful
in our individual constituencies to the
counting agents for the work which
they've done and I'd also like to thank
our the opponents here in this
constituency that we fought I think good
campaign and I don't think any others
least certainly not I've got any
complaints about how it has been
conducted - comments if I may one is
this is a disaster for the prime
minister who went into this to get a
brexit mandate and now who knows how
we're going to negotiate brexit with the
results which are coming up but the
second is a real success for labour and
Jeremy Corbyn
[Music]
you couldn't have been out in certainly
birkenhead or in where or South where I
spent time as well without feeling from
a large section of the community people
who'd put up with too much for too long
wanting to make change and we see that
in the vote here tonight in Birkenhead
we may be back of course in six months
time to try and form a majority but one
last not too frilly or point I've won
this very small rosette at every
election since 1997 and in each election
the majority has increased so I will be
wearing it hopefully next time
[Applause]